SPEAKER: So far in
this series you've
queried data stored
within BigQuery
by following a common path
of ingesting your data,
storing it, and
then analyzing it.
But it's also possible to
query data stored externally
or outside of BigQuery.
In today's episode of
"BigQuery Spotlight"
we're diving in to these
external data sources.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Wait.
So the world exists
outside of BigQuery?
Of course it does.
The good news is that
it's possible to leave
your data in place and use
BigQuery as your query engine.
We call these sources external
or federated data sources.
This functionality is
currently supported
for data residing in Google
Drive, Cloud Storage, Cloud
SQL, and Bigtable.
Before we look closer at
how to query these sources,
let's discuss a few notable
differences you'll experience
with external data sources.
First to note is that the query
performance for external data
sources may not equal the
query performance of data
stored in BigQuery.
So if query speed is a
priority in your case,
you may want to load the
data directly into BigQuery.
Secondly, when querying
an external source,
BigQuery cannot predict the
amount of data to be processed.
So you will only know
after you run your query.
Finally, the results
are not cached
like they would be when querying
data stored in BigQuery.
Caching is a great way to save
costs and improve performance
on repeated queries when the
underlying data hasn't changed.
So given these
considerations, what
are some popular use cases
for external data sources?
Overall, this feature
is best for short term,
less frequently accessed data.
For example, you could
use external data sources
to support loading and
transforming your data
in just a single pass.
In this workflow, you
query the external source,
transform the data
as part of the query,
and then write the results
as a permanent table
in BigQuery storage.
Another use case is for
joining small amounts
of frequently changing data
with data stored in BigQuery.
By keeping the
frequently changing data
as an external data
source, it does not
need to be reloaded
into BigQuery every time
it is updated.
An example here is querying data
that lives in a Google Sheet.
Even as the Sheet is
edited in real time,
you can run queries
over the data
and the results will reflect the
live, up-to-date information.
OK.
So now let's look at the how
for setting up external data
sources in BigQuery.
You can follow along in
your own BigQuery sandbox.
If you don't have
one yet, set one up
following the video link below.
In this example,
you'll run a query
over a collection of JSON files
located in a Cloud storage
bucket.
These files have the
flight performance data
for all domestic flights in
the United States from 2014.
Starting in the console,
create a new data set.
Highlight your project
name in the left hand nav
and click Create Data Set.
Name the data set
flight_performance,
choose US for the location,
and click Create Data Set.
Now highlight your new data
set and click Create Table.
Under Source, choose
Google Cloud Storage.
Quick note, if your data was
located in Google Drive--
such as in a Google Sheet--
or in Bigtable, you would
choose those alternate sources
in the dropdown.
The flight performance
data is located
in a public bucket
which any GCP user can
access with the URI address.
Paste the URI provided
in the description
below into the GCS bucket field.
You'll see there's a wild card
character in the URI, which
indicates to BigQuery to
include all the JSON files that
adhere to the specific
naming convention.
Next, under Destination,
make sure you
set the table type to external.
Name the table 2014.
And you can auto detect
the schema in this case.
Finally, click Create Table.
Since there is no data
ingestion involved,
you'll see the table immediately
populate under the data set.
Look at the table
details where you
can see the external
configuration that you just
set up and a table
size of 0 bytes
because your external table does
not use any BigQuery storage.
Now you can run a query that
references the external table.
In our query we're selecting
account of all flights
by carrier.
As we discussed earlier, you
cannot see the amount of data
processed until after
the query completes.
In this example, you created a
permanent for the external data
source.
However, you can also
query an external source
using a temporary table which
is useful for one time ad hoc
queries or for ETL processes.
More information on
how to create and query
temporary external
tables is linked below.
Want to analyze
data in Cloud SQL?
Creating the initial connection
follows a different process
than you just saw for
Cloud Storage in Drive.
But never fear, we've created
a quick start video link
below that shows
you end-to-end how
to connect to and query
your MySQL or Postgres
instance in Cloud SQL.
Looking to data sources beyond
the Google Cloud ecosystem,
we recently announced
BigQuery Omni
which gives BigQuery
users the ability
to analyze data stored
in other public clouds.
Be sure to check out
the announcement blog
post link below.
Thanks for joining us today
for "BigQuery Spotlight."
Watch out for our next episode
and remember, stay curious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]